what's up beautiful babies welcome to
another episode of get close i'm your
only
favorite host geo and i'm just a random
person in bart yeah the random dude
i was uh thinking when i was uh taking a
nap earlier
wait
how the [ __ ] are you thinking while
taking a nap you don't do that i mean
dreaming
maybe maybe dream thinking
or streaming
you don't dream
no so you know that phase before you
like really go to sleep into dreaming
and then you're just your thoughts are
wondering there's that little limbo
phase that you're kind of in control of
the dream but you're not in your brain
never do you fall asleep what the i'm
just out like a light
like a light
really so you're just like this you're
like
barring pinterest borrowing pinterest
behind prince
yup like that there's no in between nope
oh wow i know when i'm falling asleep
well i'm falling asleep because i'm
going talking
dead
talking dead talking dead dead wow
you're not in control no that's not like
i i like i i'll jolt because mine is
like this i could be like this on my
phone right like let's say we're like
it's all nice and dark took a shower
it's all like calm and comfortable i can
go like this
oh it's happening okay here that's
happening
it's happening
it's happening okay
okay wait what did you just mix what are
you drinking
what was that would you stir
this is my water wood with a straw and
you stirred it oh because you want but
i'm already i'm already asleep i'm
drinking while asleep
i already technically felt that i
already i already fell asleep and i'm
turning off the light
it's the opposite of what you do
because you know for you i'm not dead
i'm like hey babe like in the morning
right hey babe are you awake you're like
no i am not awake right now whatsoever
i'm not
i am not awake at all it is obvious and
i'm like what's one plus one like two
i'm like okay all right and then later i
go hey babe remember when i was asking
you a question you're blowing it right
in your hair you're like
oh no not at all so yeah you're in
control of your awaking process i'm in
control of my falling sleep process
that is crazy because i just die yeah
and you see me go
now i can feel it as soon as i feel it
i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm already sleeping
but i could still have a few moments to
do what i want okay so the threaming
yeah i was like man you know looking
back
have us having been on uh youtube since
what 2007 or me 2007 that's 15 years
this year right and i'm like through
that
i've experienced some crazy stuff but
then also even before that i've
experienced some crazy stuff
so like and sometimes um so you just
experience crazy stuff your whole life
is that what you're saying here and
there but then also i don't realize
that how crazy they are or sometimes i
don't i'm not remembered of it
or reminded of it
the [ __ ] is going on you dreaming yes
i'm not reminded of it until i have
conversations so i wanted to ask you um
what are some of like
the highlight moments of your life
that you've been had that like holy [ __ ]
this is happening
highlight moments okay
um so one of them
would be like uh filming jk skits
out in public
and you guys are dressed as women
or like that's a highlight moment it is
it is and this is why because i
was always super sheltered i always
wanted to do fun [ __ ] right like
obviously my my definition of fun
couldn't do any of that [ __ ] was on
complete lockdown restriction parents
were super [ __ ] strict then i go into
the workforce and then i'm following the
traditional path because i didn't know
that there was an another
path that i could even take i had no
idea that existed
then hating my [ __ ] job and then
ending up
watching my boyfriend and my friends
cross-dress and play games and make a
living off of it i was like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] this is so
[ __ ] tight
and it wasn't even like when we were
already making like
real real money in youtube it was like
before then it was the fact that i was
doing some [ __ ] that i couldn't wait to
do every single day and that was like to
show up in the office and create and
build [ __ ] like that to me was such a
moment because i'm like i'm actually
pretty broke because you couldn't
imagine a life where you actually
created and did what you want for a
living is that why uh i didn't imagine a
life being so fun like this is my job
now like i had never experienced
anything that fun
that freeing that open that accepting
like
there was never a phase in that like my
whole life that i could do anything like
that because there was always a
structure and rules and things that you
have to follow
yeah i don't think i ever had that there
was always a goal that i needed to hit
there was always things that i needed to
like tick off you know
but it was like
watching like just us [ __ ] off
and making people happy and having a
really positive message and ultimately
having a really positive impact on a
community of people that i was like
and i get paid to do this
holy [ __ ] like it was
such a rad
like realization
oh i see it was so rad
yeah i don't think you understand how
little i mean you do understand who am i
talking to but how little freedom i had
and how much i was dying inside
you do understand
i do understand
um but it may be not as i guess you do
understand but you got your wiggles out
when you started rebelling i never
rebelled and was that moment bigger
than remember when we were pitching jk
news as a tv show yeah that didn't
matter to me really yeah it didn't
matter holy [ __ ] because i wasn't doing
it to be on tv i was never doing it to
be famous i was never doing it to make
money i was doing it because it was such
a dope message uh and it was such a dope
experience
like building some [ __ ] out of nothing
like creating these funny skits like
honestly like us pitching this show to
have it be a tv show i actually didn't
like that idea at all really i didn't
want that at all because then i just
felt like these people that don't know
anything about youtube how it works
don't understand our community don't
understand us as people they're
following their business model like why
would i want to water down something
that is so [ __ ] rad already like i
just like did you ever see me get super
hyped like was i ever like oh i can't
wait
nah because i was just like there's
these like
suit wearing people
now gonna try to tell us how to like do
our [ __ ]
i'm like that is
not i viewed it so completely different
so for me um
i don't think
like in that moment of like
transitioning from this is what i went
to college and i was set to do to kind
of breaking free and then starting to do
jk and shoot the crazy skits and have
the complete schedule and literally like
your entire destiny is up to your own
hands if you want to shoot 10 skits in a
day or one a month however much money me
we made or everything is all on us it's
all on us right yeah um
that wasn't like a oh [ __ ] i can't
believe i'm here moment that was more of
a like oh [ __ ] i hope this works and we
need to survive because i think maybe
that asian guilt or something like me
knowing that i broke free from the
traditional
like doctor lawyer engineer path broke
away from school that i was just like
this haunting thing of my parents of
like this better works better work or
else i can't it's gonna be yeah you
didn't enjoy it or it's gonna be a
i told you so get your ass back to
school so i think that was uh and who
cares that they say i told you so so
what
that's i mean by the time you're an
adult that's the last thing at that age
that you want to hear oh man i didn't
give a [ __ ] because that that would have
been the i don't know 97th i told you so
and then from that point on to like now
do you trust me so
now cause you don't know me because now
because of this that's the last one i'm
going to tell you who you're going to
marry when you're going to marry her
what how she's going to buy what car
you're going to buy that's never
happened that's like the asian style
right because they're because it's like
i let you try in first grade you [ __ ]
up i let you try in second grade you
[ __ ] up you know it's all and it's
like this and i let you try for the last
time when you graduated college and you
[ __ ] up again am i gonna let you try
again no from this point on you're doing
you're only breathing when i tell you to
breathe damn i could never yeah so for
that that i think for me it was like
such a it was like
one side extremely fun but the other
side i was like oh [ __ ] i hope this
works i hope this works we better hustle
our [ __ ] asses off and not even
hustle our asses off as if like i had
like supportive american parents like
come on you got this we'll help you
we'll support you at your shows it was
more of like if i fail it's like my back
is against flames
what yeah it felt like that crazy i had
no cares
no cares at all like i was already the
black sheep i didn't have a really good
relationship with my parents like i was
already a [ __ ] off you know yeah but
like i i was always like i didn't need
to like i i always felt like
for as you like far back as i can
remember i always needed to convince my
parents that my way was correct for me
yeah you know so i was always doing that
so i think i just got used to that going
like you don't understand you don't get
it you know and then them going like
you're so stupid like why would you give
up a good job why would you do like just
everything i ever did was just the worst
decision ever have you ever
won in that competition in what
competition the one you just said i'm
i'm winning now no no but prior
obviously now we're i'm not before i did
everything that well i didn't do
everything that they wanted me to do but
like i followed the path the secure path
right like i well i guess once i moved
out on my own that was already so i
think that's probably the difference
i've literally failed a thousand times
like being arrested been kicked out of
school switched you know like so i think
for me it's like this is my first
freedom moment that i earned for myself
i have to capitalize on this privilege
right because you were goody two shoes
so it's like you never really had a
uh you never failed in that competition
you never really failed it was like go
to school okay stay inside okay you know
like go to school okay i didn't remember
okay okay okay okay okay and then so for
you you're like i'm an adult now i don't
give a [ __ ] exactly for me it's like go
to this [ __ ] you fail see you're coming
crawling back home do this fail so
you're crawling back home again so it's
crawling back home seven thousand times
where it's like hey you better get your
ass in front go to medical school am i
not on at this time
oh this time what about the other 9 000
other times
you know so i know that if i failed then
it was like
yo we're done doing this [ __ ]
crawling on your knees game buddy got it
it's like that yeah yeah yeah no i
followed what they wanted
um up until the point where i'm like all
right i'm i'm grown now that's it
you're you can't control that anymore
you were able to control it this far i
let you
um i still kind of rebelled in my own
way but not as hard as you at all not
even close
um and then i was like that's it you
can't tell me [ __ ] anymore yeah so i
think for me
when we start first started pitching jk
news as a tv show
um
the part that i was like
oh [ __ ]
is like growing up in la you drive up
and down like the 101 right the 405 and
stuff and you see the nbc building the
universal building you see all those
buildings
and in your mind you tie the two and two
together you know you're like oh [ __ ]
like that's where the meetings go down
for like the walking dead all these sons
of anarchy or like like robin big like
you know you you tie all that stuff
together
um but you never know what goes on in
those buildings
so and you watch a bunch of like tv type
shows like the entourage or whatever
like hollywood shows so you kind of have
a glimpse of what goes on inside those
buildings but not really
and then so
from a perspective of
i don't want this to fail
to jk doing pretty good right like we're
able to feed like a team of like 20 30
people
where no one really had to have another
job like that's doing pretty damn good
so that was like okay cool
check that box not crawling back to my
parents
we're good
in my mind though because we invented
everything ourselves our shooting style
our own shooting schedule
even assigning each other roles like you
are the you are in charge of writing
the next jakey party challenge
and you're the scorpion gatherer you
know and you're this guy and you're
gonna clean uh bart's piss off the tree
and like we're literally just [ __ ]
ragtag everything
so for a ragtag group that invented
everything i was like we're on
the [ __ ] 34th floor
of this building and we're gonna meet
the vp
of mtv
this is [ __ ] crazy like i felt like
it's uh someone that taught themselves
how to street fight and then somehow
ended up in dana white's room that's
pretty tight you know and i'm like these
moments like this
is what history books are made of
history books aren't made of
like the
the former scenario we talked about
where this guy he became completely
creative and then he took his life into
his own hand like that doesn't make the
history pages you know what makes the
history pages is if there was like
of something of like 20 2000 to 2020
it's like these guys came from nothing
and like the rock right he came from
nothing and then now have the biggest tv
show on whatever so i was like oh [ __ ]
we're on track this is [ __ ] crazy and
then so almost every
single meeting that we had from mtv nbc
whatever comedy central um when i go in
those buildings i was just like taking
it all in i was like studying the
elevators the elevator buttons the
[ __ ] receptionist i was oh [ __ ] they
got water stored over there this is
[ __ ] crazy
yeah that's that's how like that was
like one of one of the highlight moments
of
of that era so that's your highlight
moment no i got tons of highlight
moments but that's i was just saying
like i wanted to share like because
these things like when i talk to taiko
when i'm playing with him
i feel like it's one of those
conversations where like one day he'll
talk to me and oh yeah papa used to
pitch tv shows too
and he goes yeah [ __ ] right and i'm
like
i honestly i didn't it says nbc
comedy central i'll list all of me like
yeah all right my [ __ ] daddy's
[ __ ] you know i'm like yeah i was in
the vp with an mtv program and he was
like
oh god okay dad okay you sit you know
but then when when i
i don't want these moments to like
just disappear because now in this phase
of my life a lot of these moments i've
noticed have been
subdued and i'm not as impressed by
myself
anymore but i but when we talk about it
i'm like oh [ __ ] we [ __ ] did a lot
like even when like when i'm shooting jk
news with the current cast right now
like i'm sitting there we're having a
[ __ ] good ass time right and i'm like
dude this [ __ ]
won
a tv show yeah this guy got second place
at a tv show
and i'm like
and they're here
sitting on ikea furniture
in a [ __ ] building you know hey those
are not ikea chairs bro yeah yeah but it
was like it's like stuff like that
expensive chairs stuff that like that
that reminds me of like wow that was
[ __ ] cool
yeah i think we have a thing and this
could be like culturally yeah how we
were raised yeah like we don't ever
really celebrate any of our victories
you know what i mean like we've done a
lot but when have we ever like had this
conversation never that's why that's
what i was like dude we [ __ ] did a
lot but we never
like like celebrate or even debrief
you know it's literally like we do that
meeting and whether it goes good or not
it's like okay pretend i didn't even
happen okay uh so we should get we get
korean bbq or and it's just like a day
as usual first dude guys this is [ __ ]
awesome i can't believe we did this all
the hard work there's like none of that
stuff no no brief before and no debrief
after yeah it's kind of like
embarrassing a little bit to be put in
like in the limelight like that yeah
it's like uh well i guess i'm just good
it's because i'm doing my job i'm
supposed to be doing this this is why
we're here because i did a good job
yeah we don't ever talk about any of
that [ __ ] i didn't feel weird talking
about it now oh really yeah cause i'm
like well what's the po what's the point
to celebrate and to remember yeah
because a lot of these stories like when
i um you know when i was doing my times
100
uh my little mentorship group or when we
get booked to do shows when i like tell
these stories it's very like inspiring
and it's a peep a peek into a world that
many have seen before
you know yeah like the other day we were
talking and we're like um
we're going on our jk walks right and
then we're just talking and then i was
sharing with all the dudes i was like
yeah taika like loves blade right now
like that's his favorite movie and i'm
like oh man i should bring it back and
they're like oh dude they are bringing
it back i'm like who the [ __ ] gonna
play him who's [ __ ] cooler than
wesley snipes like wesley snipes
actually has martial arts training
and then uh someone said the actual name
of the new actor i barely even knew him
and i'm like dude he's not going to have
that wesley's like snipes swag
and then we started talking like oh i
knew it would be awesome michael j white
i'm like oh yeah and i'm like dude did
you know i've been at a party with them
and they're like what i'm like yeah a
house party too he was standing right
next to me i was [ __ ] like scoping
him up and down i'm like oh this
[ __ ] is huge
and stuff like that where like early on
in jk
when uh this is before i think even uh
you or casey even came on the team this
is me and joe and danny shooting
um
this guy named arnold chan he's like a
pretty big guy in stunt world
he was such a big fan that he was like
can he come over to my house
i'm gonna host the ufc
and i'm like oh should i recognize that
guy because he i used to watch a lot of
the paul mitchell like uh karate
championship like competition videos
paul mitchell the hair guy yeah i don't
know why but he hosted all these karate
like so if you ever see like flashy
nunchucks
like some crazy like music with karate i
don't know why but they're the ones that
threw all those events
so uh and then arnold would win them all
the time and i'm like that's [ __ ]
arnold he reached out to me what the
[ __ ] so i remember going to his house
and then he's like hey what's up man and
dude i would just see like the a bunch
of who's who's that i recognize in a
bunch of movies i'm like oh dude that's
[ __ ] henchman number five in like uh
like like a in like let's say rush hour
the big asian guy that carried the guy
over there and i would just see and then
uh next to the couch was [ __ ] wesley
snipes he was sitting on the couch with
his mom like this is how [ __ ] chill
and laid back it is with his mom because
him and
arnold actually grew up in a think like
in virginia together or they trained
karate or martial arts together and i'm
watching the fight
with wesley snipes
and wesley snipes is just cracking jokes
and [ __ ] and i'm like
i don't even know if it was funny or not
you can't even hear me but i just but i
just wanted to be in it you know and i
look over i'm like what the [ __ ] that's
michael's giant white that's my [ __ ]
spawn
that's a universal soldier
the [ __ ] going on
you know and then uh then i said what is
that dustin win the [ __ ] from 21 jump
street the original one i'm like what
the [ __ ] this is [ __ ] crazy
and then you know and then like i was
almost scared for anyone to ask
what me and joe did or like how we know
arnold because i'm like oh uh yeah we do
like this uh like everyday
go to school
too you know but that was one of those
like
oh [ __ ] moments too like i've actually
been in a house
with wesley snipes and michael jy this
episode is brought to you by zip
recruiter certain people
just make my life so much easier and i
don't even know what i do without them
like for example in both my companies in
jk and barlow brigade i have a set
manager for both
and what that allows me to do is to stay
creative and stay on the visionary
aspect because
like honest to god i'm actually not that
good at operations and logistics and
like all the fine details of things and
making sure that this department
communicates with the other department
and they work synergistically that is
definitely not one of my traits my
traits is thinking kind of outside the
box and you know creating new pathways
for the business and for it to scale so
i'm super happy that i'm able to have
managers in both companies that are able
to kind of take my weakness turn that
into a strength for the company because
that's their strength and i can focus on
my strength and so if you have a growing
business and you need to hire
ziprecruiter makes hiring so much easier
because they do the work for you and
right now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
get close
ziprecruiter uses a powerful technology
to find and match the right candidates
with your job and you can easily review
these recommended candidates and even
invite your top choices to apply which
is awesome because usually it would be
people just applying you know directly
if they heard about your company but if
you're growing business not that many
people might even know what you do so
it's cool to be able to go under just
the candidates section and just invite
people like hey i know you might not
have heard of my growing company but i
need or could use someone just like you
and we can have a great relationship and
you invite them to
apply which is
six so four and four out of five
employers would post on zip recruiter
get a quality candidate within the first
day so if you're in a fast paced
industry
this is freaking awesome in fact the
hardest thing you have to do is remember
our special url so make sure just use
that ziprecruiter.com get close that's
where you go to try ziprecruiter for
free once again that's ziprecruiter.com
s g-e-t-c-l-o-s-e yeah that's tight yeah
that's really cool i don't know if mine
um my moments are like that though where
it's like
it seems like yours hit like a certain
like accolades like threshold you know
what i mean like
like
like for you it doesn't have to be
okay well these these two sound like it
but i mean i'm just talking about any
moment that you're like it's a oh [ __ ]
moment hmm so it could be like [ __ ]
tied up in the back of a trunk oh [ __ ]
i'm here yep i'm kidnapped
what the [ __ ] this is crazy
you know why am i in baja california i
don't know
why do you keep talking like that
because it's a oh [ __ ] moment that's
what ocean
moments like they they feel like that
you know it's almost an out-of-body
experience
damn
i don't know
i'm like the worst when [ __ ] calling
back memories dude
really yeah
what about this conversation what about
this what about when uh
jk
got booked to do an australia tour
and we're touring with
periodics
and we're flying and we know we're
hitting sydney melbourne brisbane perth
we're doing a [ __ ] nationwide tour
we're on posters
everywhere
there was not a single oh [ __ ] moment
like
like because growing up
when i hear people go on tour i'm
thinking of like [ __ ] justin
timberlake yeah or like [ __ ] 98
degrees or some [ __ ] like yeah people
when they when they say i'm going on
tour
it's like
some big ass [ __ ] people yeah you
know you don't hear local bands going oh
yeah i'm going on tour it's like oh [ __ ]
you're going on tour dude that's like
some green day [ __ ] you know yeah so
when i was like some people go where are
you going next i'm going on tour i'm
like as it comes out of my mouth i'm
like oh [ __ ] i said it i said those
[ __ ] green day type words i'm going
on tour how many cities for four cities
you didn't have that feeling mm-hmm what
was you you're just i was [ __ ] i'm
going to australia whatever the [ __ ] um
i think because i was in such a big
planning mode and i wanted to make sure
everything was running smoothly i think
i was having your moment of not being
able to enjoy because there was so much
pressure uh yeah because i'm the one
booking everything i'm the one
coordinating everything i'm the one like
sending in like the the writer and
making sure we get paid and making sure
that you guys are okay like i was just
so
work
that like um
yeah i didn't have an oh [ __ ] moment it
was just like this is tight but i gotta
make sure everything runs smoothly what
about when we were in um
i think of sydney
and we were in that historical building
that they said lady gaga and justin
bieber performs at
and then uh
damn because when they told us that
and then we came on stage and i saw like
the thousands of people that was a
packed house
i was like oh it was another like oh
[ __ ] justin bieber performed lady gaga
performed and then when i went
downstairs to green room to change i was
like this is where the grades have
changed
holy [ __ ]
no
wow never mm-hmm well i think because
i'm too i was too focused on
again making sure everything went
smoothly because so like
i need you guys to like perform i need
you guys to be happy and creative and
only focus on your craft so i was taking
on a lot of like
the stress
you know like your guys's stress is the
performance stress my stress and like
nailing it my stress was like all the
logistics what about this okay what
about when uh we were
in more close proximity with the
stereotypes okay and you're at their
studio in west l.a and christina milian
walks in you want like oh [ __ ] that's
crystal meena million no cause it's
christina milian
what the [ __ ] she's big
not in my world she wasn't big i didn't
care for r b in any of that [ __ ] you
know what i mean like she was just
someone that like what about walking
through the hallways and seeing like
platinum records from bieber like
platinum records from like well i
interned at universal music so i had
already experienced stuff like that yeah
but that's not a personal interaction
that's more like i'm here to work yeah
but i was still exposed to it you know
what i mean like that time i walked into
universal for the first time that was an
oh [ __ ] moment for me because i'm like
oh [ __ ] like i'm a chick from the
[ __ ] barrio that's like about that
moment that's like here this is wild
yeah that's right i mean i have a lot i
have a lot of those but not pertaining
necessarily to jk it doesn't have to be
joking that's what i was saying even if
you're kidnapped in a trunk
that's a oh that's the one yeah
i was like i was trying to tie it back
to it i'm like what no that's what i'm
saying
any moment that you found yourself
in a oh [ __ ] like you could be tied up
in the trunk in baja california like you
got kidnapped by the cartoon the first
oh [ __ ] that i can think of is um
when i had my my really big accident
like the one that left me with scars on
my face yeah yeah um
so we were
we were at my uncle's ranch out in like
valencia or some [ __ ] like that and um
like at this time my sister's boyfriend
was like heavy mechanic he loved buying
like beat up cars and bikes and just any
toy and he loved fixing him and he was
like a really
uh he was like a brainiac when it came
to restoring things
so um he had bought a motorcycle and
this quad and we were gonna go spend
like the weekend out there we're gonna
have like a barbecue live band like it
was just gonna be fun fun times right
because it's just [ __ ] dead and he
has acres and acres of land so we're
just gonna [ __ ] off
so we're there and i'm like my dad's
favorite
i'll say it i don't know my siblings
might think they're the favorite but i'm
for sure his [ __ ] favorite so it was
uh we were gonna go racing and he would
call me prieta which is like it doesn't
matter um
derogatory term well kind of well it's
not derogatory but like like
like uh like dark skinned girl or
whatever right
um but it just it loses its its um lots
of translation well it loses its like
cuniness in translation like it just
sounds harsh oh is it kind of one of
those things where like it's like an
endearing like when i call taika like
stinker yes it's like it's like that i
don't really mean he's thinking yeah
because he's not stinky but but it's
okay that is my loss and prieta too is
more so like saying like i'm like he
would say because i was like a dirty
like a dirty little tomboy girl that was
like i hated taking showers so like i
had like dirt on my neck
so yeah shut the [ __ ] up i mean he said
i'm glad i took a shower on sunday yeah
thank you um so yeah so he's like
let's go you know and we were gonna race
and we were just gonna ride out with my
sister's boyfriend at the time
um so he speeds up we're behind him
because he had bought this stuff like he
was still in the middle of restoring we
don't have seat belts i don't have a
helmet we didn't think we're gonna go
that nuts or maybe we just thought we
were safer or maybe my dad
just made a [ __ ] dumb decision
my boyfriend my sister's boyfriend
speeds up he like swerves i'm not paying
attention to it because i'm like what
nine
eight nine i'm like a little ass kid and
um
all i remember is seeing this big ass
like
like ditch [ __ ] yeah yeah
the quad where are you sitting in the
front in the front between my dad's legs
oh [ __ ] he's like driving you guys
racing here
yeah well we were just following him oh
okay
but we were going fast
and um so i see this ditch approaching
we get stuck we get launched out and all
i remember hearing is just the dirt
underneath me as i fell it's just like
you know when you're walking or like you
scrape your foot yeah it was like that
yeah like the dirt and the rocks and
stuff
and then um i just remember feeling
really hot on my face
and like from that point until my sister
got there i don't really remember i
don't even know maybe he drove off
because there's no cell phones at this
time
and then uh
uh i'm in the car we're driving to the
emergency room oh you probably got
knocked out huh probably you're
unconscious um we're driving in yeah
we're in the car and i remember like i
couldn't see out of this eye i don't
know why but i couldn't see out of the
side that freaked you out
no and then my sister yeah i didn't know
what was happening you weren't like holy
boy i can't see i can't see you what the
[ __ ] no because um everyone's like
you're gonna be fine everything's fine
okay i'm fine right my sister's like geo
you can't fall asleep dude you can't
fall asleep please wake up wake up wake
up you keep going wake up and i was like
i'm awake but she's like it was just my
eye was swollen oh um
so i'm at the doc at the er get x-rays
and the doctor's like i'm so surprised
you didn't break any bone in your face
because that was such a hard
fall yeah and at that point i was like
oh
[ __ ]
like i'm in a [ __ ] hospital right now
and like
i had a big ass accident
it was a [ __ ] pretty gnarly accident
my dad's [ __ ] head was all bandaged
oh [ __ ] i got [ __ ] up yeah he got
[ __ ] up um and we were both
pretty [ __ ] up like i think i slept
for like maybe two days
and like it was my face was all [ __ ]
like all of this was just [ __ ] up and
i was scratched all over and i was like
and everyone was being so nice to me
like all my siblings were being so nice
to me and people were checking in on me
and i was like not used to it and i'm
like didn't you didn't get a chance to
see what you look like um maybe a few
days later and i looked pretty [ __ ] up
like my eye was all fat and like that i
had ointment all over my face so i was
just all glossy and [ __ ] and i'm like
[ __ ] i could have died
i'm like
holy [ __ ] yeah that was a big one for me
wow does your mom let go
yeah you're not taking our daughters out
anymore
i don't know i don't remember them
having that type of conversation i think
my dad like i remember seeing my dad
crying for me my brother cried for me
they were really scared so i don't even
know why they were crying because when i
think back at it unless they downplayed
it a lot
which now i'm thinking they did because
like you said once you recall the
memories
um
but like i'm like why would they cry
unless it was really bad yeah
yeah but they came to my bedside and
they were crying
but i was in so much pain i remember
like my whole body [ __ ] hurt
one of the ocean movements that i had
too was um this is when i was in the
marine corps
and uh so my
job
was supply administration
so i'm supposed to be like running a
warehouse keeping inventory of equipment
and all that stuff like that
and uh but what was crazy is whatever i
went to mls school for mos was just drop
schooling when i got to my unit i did
none of it
because my unit was so special was third
inglico which stands for air naval gun
liaison company so they did a lot of
really special things as a unit because
uh they supported a lot of like the
special operation stuff oh cool so we
were able to get into a lot of like
secret bases on camp pendleton and this
is like the first time because you know
marine corps is all about rex
regulations which is like tight haircuts
like you know pressed uniforms all that
[ __ ]
this this is the first time where we
went into camp pendleton behind like
some sort of like secret fence that's
inside of camp so it's like a base
inside of a base inside of a base
we show up and then uh
the marines that greet us they're like
kind of lower rank like corporals or
whatever
and they have like earrings and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] beards and then they're like
half uniform half not so like denim
pants and then uniform top all of these
are completely
completely you cannot [ __ ] do that
they're talking to our officers not
saying sir or anything just talking to
my buds and [ __ ] and i'm like
this is some [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] so
that's just like one example of like the
type of cool stuff we're able to do but
my oh [ __ ] moment is
um because our unit is so small
and uh our ceo which is our company
commander like
he wants our unit to be like [ __ ]
tough active and nimble so he doesn't
give a [ __ ] what anyone's job is
he wants everyone to stay like locked in
so when we go out to the field which is
pretty much like once every single month
they'll go like hey i want every
department or every section to send a
marine
so that means like you could be motor t
or you could be which is motor transport
or you could be personal admin or you
could be supply you could be whatever
every section has to send one marine so
when you're the junior marine
they're gonna send you because
if not uh if you get to stay back then
you have a normal military schedule show
up at like i don't know like six or
something go home at four go home and
sleep party do whatever come back the
next day yeah so they don't want to go
yeah but if you're in the field you're
sleeping there and your ass is there's
the whole weekend which could be two or
three four days or whatever right so i'm
always the one getting sent because i'm
the new marine
so i go
um and then they force some jobs onto me
because uh most of my unit is full of
forward observers there are the guys
that are like in in terms of like in
battle they're the guys that jump out of
airplanes like kind of and then they're
able to like do some recon type stuff
look at things and then call for fire if
they need to that's where like the air
naval gun liaison
ties into together so my my unit had a
lot of fos which is our forward
observers so they're usually doing f o
[ __ ] which is like pretty cool [ __ ]
where i go like man i should have signed
up for this [ __ ] man my recruiter did a
really bad job explaining jobs yeah he
was sleeping under her desk dude what
did you want yeah so i i uh
i go there they're forcing a job for me
to do because i'm not qualified to do
some of the other stuff
and this is one of the biggest oh [ __ ]
moments so we had a live call for fire
exercise
and i remember i'm sitting in the back
of a seven ton seven ton or like those
really giant military looking like uh
semi trucks
i'm sitting on the back with my legs
dangling because i already did what i
needed to do
everything else is uh besides what i'm
qualified to do and they do a call for
fire which means these four observers
they call for exact coordinate for
people to come down and like unleash
hell on
so i see them go out there at map get
the coordinates whatever
they
they phone it in and then you see these
jets come from like way far away
like this and then i was like holy [ __ ]
am i in a michael bay movie what the
[ __ ] is this because up to then
most of your training is like a lot of
like tough personal stuff hiking hiking
hiking [ __ ] miles and miles and miles
and miles you know like [ __ ] digging
foxholes and [ __ ] sleeping in there
[ __ ] at the range pew pew pew pew so
a lot of it is like kind of like ground
infantry work
you don't really get to see like
the the other flexes of the military you
know like black [ __ ] like
like that kind of [ __ ] or whatever right
so you see you don't see any of the [ __ ]
that they pitched in the commercial yeah
you don't get to see like top gun [ __ ]
yeah you're not crawling out of [ __ ]
what are they pawns or whatever that
[ __ ] that a swamp yeah you're doing like
like grunt infantry stuff and then i see
this
like that and when they drive uh flew by
[Music]
and the whole [ __ ] ground is shaking
and i'm like
that's [ __ ] crazy it was like the
craziest fireworks and [ __ ] that i've
ever seen you just see them take off
[ __ ] like flying in formation
fly out in formation how cool and then
uh
it's like literally seconds
but me with the knowledge that i know
i'm like dude that was [ __ ] millions
of dollars you know jet fuel
missiles
all that [ __ ] and to be able to have
like experience that and i was like damn
like i think that was the moment that
made me really grateful
because at that moment i'm trying to
get my bachelor's at ucla right so when
i'm trying to get my bachelor's at ucla
every single week and i need to study
so when i go to my reserve duty
i'm always like praying to god i'm like
pray don't send me to the field don't
send me to the field i need to go back
and study please please please please
please please please
and when they sent every time they send
me to the field i'm like ah [ __ ] now i
gotta go xerox yeah i gotta go [ __ ]
xerox some bio books or some [ __ ] that's
gonna throw my schedule all out of i
can't lift either so my there goes my
[ __ ] gains so i'll
i'll pour like protein powder and a zip
lock bag and stuff in my cargo pocket
and if i gotta do all this [ __ ] weird
[ __ ]
but
when i was at that moment and i saw all
of that go down i'm like damn i saw a
live call for fire
which i would have never have been able
to to see because i would have just been
in the library study yeah and i'm like
that was [ __ ] cool that is [ __ ]
cool yeah fine another um oh [ __ ] moment
for me is the first time i actually got
to fly
to paris on my own like without family
and like that was with you that was my
first like real international flight
like i had been to mexico but i was so
little and like mexico so like close not
to knock on mexico or anything but i
just didn't consider it there's a field
international yeah that's like crossing
into canada it's like yes it's
international but and you need a
passport but it doesn't feel
international yeah so that was like
super life-changing for me because um so
much had changed in my life at that
point like i had
defied my parents um
uh rules i guess and i left
the house without being married with
like i actually got their consent which
is dope and at that time i had already
repaired or i was in the beginning
phases of repairing my relationship with
my dad whom i hadn't talked to
even though we lived in the same house
for like four years like several years i
can't even remember now because it's so
old now
um but that move
or me pitching that move is what
prompted us to start talking again
because i was like hey you know what i
have to talk to you about something
i know i [ __ ] up i know like for all
these years we haven't talked we don't
like each other whatever whatever
i just want to say on my part that i'm
sorry for anything that happened
but i will be moving out you know this
is my plan or whatever and then that is
when
that was also a big oh [ __ ] moment for
me too where i'm like holy [ __ ] like
like you're having even having an adult
conversation with my dad one
that's a very adult conversation with my
dad two i'm actually going to move out
three
which our other two older siblings
didn't even do no they didn't they
followed the path which is married and
then get out yeah yeah like i stood up
to the big beast yeah like
i stood up to the big guy like he's the
[ __ ]
our house is a country and he's like the
prime minister like he is the guy or the
dictator probably the dictator for sure
he is the dick i'm just kidding i love
you dad um
but yeah like i stood up to that you
know and like to have an adult
conversation and
to have him talk back to me and we'd
like actually squash it that was an oh
[ __ ] moment for me that's cool so then
moving out he actually helped me move
out which is another kind of like
miniature oh [ __ ] because i'm like holy
[ __ ] like not only do i have his support
um he's actually helping me out so then
we get together
i've been saving or we have like a
little travel fund that we like put
money in every single month we're
finally able to afford a trip out to
paris
i think all we put was like 100 bucks
each a month too yeah but then years
later that was like 2 400 bucks yeah and
it was perfect that's all we needed
we're still broke but we made it happen
um i remember
flying into paris
and like
i was like like i i don't even know if
you remember but i like i was crying
like i just like maybe i was fighting my
tears back because i wasn't very
vulnerable back then but like i was like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] i can't believe i made
this happen like
oh how am i here right now this is so
[ __ ] crazy like i was so moved
that's cuny yeah do you remember what
you saw through the window
um so everything was snowing and that's
when we were like
[ __ ] we packed all the wrong clothes
um and we were just flying back flying
into like a lot of farmland it was just
like empty fields everywhere
and i'm like holy [ __ ] and that changed
my perspective on life forever like that
trip i'm like i ain't [ __ ] i want more
of this i like i'm so tiny the city i
grew up in is so insignificant like i
need i need more of this like i need to
expand my horizons like crazy like it
really put into perspective how little i
had lived even though i was like 20
something i'm still fairly young but i'm
like i haven't experienced [ __ ]
that is crazy when you go into another
country because i think growing up you
always think like your city is the [ __ ]
or whatever and you feel like you think
everything is america yeah and you feel
like you know everything
and then you go to another country and
then the little old language that you
grew up on is insignificant there and
you're like
what the [ __ ] yeah and then you hear
music playing from restaurants and
you're like hey that's that ratatouille
[ __ ]
gratitude didn't exist yet yeah but yeah
yeah yeah but you hear like that's that
mime [ __ ] yeah you hear that [ __ ]
french [ __ ]
and then they're like
damn
that's a real ass baguette what th just
[ __ ] right there yeah it was gnarly
like i couldn't believe that i had made
that happen i'm like
what
i'm not supposed to be here right now
like that's not what my family does we
don't we don't do [ __ ] like this we stay
in cars and we [ __ ] drive
locally and [ __ ] or we just don't go
anywhere i'm like
how the [ __ ] am i here right now
that's when like i think traveling
really made me go like man
there are billions of people
in the world
just living
their own lives
and so whatever i am thinking
in my own opinions
doesn't [ __ ] matter everyone has
their own
lives dreams struggles whatever
situations and they're just
like you could just sit there and people
watch right you're like oh oh that's
them on the way to work okay grabbing a
roll
walking like
my own oh
my mom wants me to go to medical school
oh
it's like they don't give a [ __ ] that's
my own [ __ ] problem you're not even
in their line of sight exactly so i'm
like who am i crying to use myself a
little bit well and me because i'm in
the [ __ ] room too i know
just kidding but yeah that was a big one
for me because like
i don't like i just deviated so far from
what was expected of me that i'm like i
cannot believe i'm making this happen
like i cannot believe i'm pulling this
[ __ ] off
like every step of the way i'm like i
can't believe i'm gonna do it i can't
believe i did it i can't believe it
worked like that's i think that's been
my life my whole life
where i'm always going like
[ __ ] it i gotta do it oh my god i'm
doing it oh [ __ ] it worked oh [ __ ]
that happens quite a bit in my life i
like uh when we're on that little like
um boat thing that was going down that
river
and then we got into a big ass fight we
fought a lot yeah that was like early
stages of a relationship and then
i dropped the [ __ ] lens cap well that
wasn't there
i will never forget where you dropped it
i thought i'd drop it off i thought i
dropped it off the boat you weren't on a
boat so we were like on the canals yeah
on these canal thingies and then um
we did fight a lot but that wasn't a
moment when we were fighting we
definitely fought afterwards but so you
had bought me this camera because i i
showed interest in wanting to get into
photography and then i got pissed with
you the entire [ __ ] trip because you
wouldn't let me exp like you wouldn't
let me play with my own [ __ ] camera
because you're like let me see this oh
here and then you would take it over and
i'm like i don't even want it anymore
anyway thank you for letting me vet uh
no matter what years later i'm still
holding on to it um
so you know like the the canals where
those
those boats are yeah so we climbed to
the bottom and you were taking uh i was
taking pictures of you and you were
posing and then just you started getting
really goofy and you were jumping and
then i think it fell out of your pocket
and then it fell into the thing
and i was like
that's the [ __ ] last [ __ ]
straw like not only can i not play with
my camera but you're [ __ ] up my
camera
yeah i was so pissed at you the minute
it fell in i was like that's the [ __ ]
last thing i i need right now because
now she has more ammunition to [ __ ]
going on i was so
[ __ ] pissed at you i was like mother
[ __ ] dude he [ __ ] around too much
yeah i was just i
if funny enough i mean i still had a fun
time on that trip you know we fought so
goddamn much there's even pictures of me
with like red eyes and a red nose
because i think i was just so angry most
of the time i was crying
[ __ ]
hated it but like i have nothing but
really good memories of it honestly like
if i think back to it i'm just like it
was so funny watching you put on my
[ __ ] pantyhose because it was so
[ __ ] cool i needed it you wore my
clothes um it was also really cool that
like we that was the first time
and this was years ago but that was the
first time we went into a restaurant
because they consume a lot of steak
right so we're eating at the steak house
or not even a steakhouse it's probably
just like a regular cafe they come and
we're like we asked for the check but
then he has like that portable machine
where we just pay at the table and i was
like
this is i think is this oh
2009 sir where are we living you know
because i'm used to just going to a
register yeah yeah yeah and he like did
that um i remember all of like the
subways look super rad oh [ __ ] paris
i love it i love it so much yeah but it
was such a good trip
but yeah i just my mind was blown that i
like
was in another country my fondest memory
from that trip is um i remember both of
us were so [ __ ] tired and jet lagged
so not only were we jet lag but it was
cold as [ __ ] we couldn't wait to be
under blankets and then we would like
see the city and they're like okay let's
go back for a nap or so both [ __ ]
tired okay cool and jet lag so we're
like taking a nap or like we'll just set
that alarm for like an hour or something
and then we'll knock out
and then like
when we wake up like hey babe dude you
want to just sleep like another hour and
you're like yeah yeah yeah okay oh
and it was set for another hour
and beep beep beep
hey do you want to wake up for another
hour and i remember one of the days i
think we slept the whole day away and
they were like horrible when we woke up
it was like 9 00 p.m or something
horrible we're like
[ __ ]
we wasted a whole day in paris what the
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah that was a that
was a definite oh [ __ ] for me for sure
that's tight is that what you say oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] mommy yeah yeah yeah okay
that's one do you have another one oh
yeah i'm thinking
there's a lot there's like so many from
like all different like realms fine i'll
tell you another one
um
so
in college i never knew what i wanted to
do right i've told
i i've shared with you that like
you know in the igetc like [ __ ] jc
there's like a sheet yeah to transfer to
a four year yeah and then like i was
looking at like what i needed to do and
i was like well i [ __ ] i don't even know
what my major is and i remember they
showed me a sheet of all the majors and
i was like [ __ ]
i don't know what i want
and it's crazy to think that like at 20
year old at 20 years old you should
already know what you're gonna be doing
for the rest of your life isn't that
gnarly and then you're gonna go into
crazy anyway
also you're gonna go into crazy that you
don't even know if you like it whatever
so i remember looking at that sheet and
then going okay i like business okay
well what's under business
okay accounting finance
i'm not good at that marketing
marketing and i was thinking ads
commercials and i'm like i'll go with
that i mean that is it right like all
the ad agencies they hire the marketers
i mean there's a bunch of things in
marketing it's such a broad
super duper broad um uh what is it major
like it you could do so much i see but i
just didn't know anything else so i was
like i'll just go into that so
did my college it was i think i was like
my senior or junior year at a four year
about to graduate and i'm like [ __ ] i
have no idea what i want to do like i
want to eventually end up like at an ad
agency like i remember looking up all
these ad agencies that i eventually
wanted to go to like some in london a
lot of them are actually in london like
marketing is huge out there at that time
at least like all the top tier ones were
there and i'm like fine i'm gonna go
there and then i don't even remember how
i found out about this but there was an
internship at universal music and i'm
like i [ __ ] love music let's go
applied i get the internship my first
day on the job it's like at the
universal building building yeah and
it's like security and you got to check
in and you need a badge and then i go up
to the floor like everything looks very
corporate in suits once i get to the
level the
universal music level
um
that's when it was [ __ ]
rad it was so tight that's where i saw
all the albums or like the the records
and stuff and then like they had like
this board room that's glass
and like all the people that
are signed under their label like no
doubt britney spears like all the
[ __ ] heavy hitters of that time had
all autographed this wall and i'm like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] everyone i love
has walked these [ __ ] grounds i'm
like
holy [ __ ] and that was like the first
time i saw like the break room had like
every [ __ ] snack you can think of
they were like
it was just such a rad experience like
everywhere you looked everyone's space
was super
[ __ ] decked out and decorated and
super artistic and stuff um that's why
when you're like the christina emilian
and all that stuff i'm like and whatever
but that was in person though it was but
it was still like a whatever because
like she's not someone i i listened to
anyway
like i was listening to no doubt i was
listening to like youtube uh to youtube
i was listening to like wallflowers like
like lauren hill like
like
that's that side of things you know
like pop music i didn't give a [ __ ] but
seeing someone in person to me is just
crazy it was crazy but not like
like memorable like i had forgotten
until you mentioned it you know like i
always remember when i saw marcus
houston at cheesecake factory that's
funny remember we saw him yeah yeah yeah
and even then i was like this is when we
first started dating and i was like
oh [ __ ] we saw usher i was like is that
omarion and marcus houston
just eating the [ __ ] same roles i'm
eating yeah cheesecake factory yeah i'm
like remember we saw usher at the
[ __ ] bellagio in that like garden
section he he walked by us and you're
like i think that's a shirt
i think that's usher and i was like
yeah because you're you have a really
good eye of finding the doppelganger yes
i thought it was a doppelganger thing
again i'm like nah it's not and i'm like
holy [ __ ] that's [ __ ] usher and he
just walked by yeah watch this yeah
yeah
yeah for some reason my my eyes are good
at catching people i remember walking
just down caesar's palace
um and then i was like oh [ __ ] that's
robert ori that's robert ori and no one
and jk uh really watches sports that
much except for david and he's like holy
[ __ ] that is robert what the [ __ ]
and it was just crazy i just i was like
because he's not even like like like a
marketed star right he's not like uh
like a tim duncan or like you know kobe
bryant or whatever yeah yeah it was just
it's like if you know if you watch
basketball you'd know who he is but it
was just i was like oh [ __ ] that's him
my eyes were
just caught on yeah one of the uh oh
[ __ ] moments um that i felt that was
pretty crazy
was uh remember when they were gonna
bring back and live in color yeah oh
yeah that's a big one for me so yeah
like um
living color is a
show it's like it like the the kind of
legacy is
key and peel everyone knows
that was like they built their roots in
mad tv
mad tv then built their roots in living
color so that's like the original
originator like type of like sketch
comedy show so it's something that me
and joe grew up on and we [ __ ] loved
it
and that's the come up of [ __ ] um a
lot of our like the the wayne's
all the waynes brothers and sisters yeah
jim carrey jlo like there's so many yeah
so many people yeah jlo even they all
came from there
jayla was a dancer
all the mega stars that we know of today
came from there and uh
a super dope casting director at the
time um because that was something
that's really cool
about the wayne's family is when they're
recasting for a living color they wanted
to be multicultural too just like that
so i think they're like oh man we're
missing like some uh some like color in
this group right so they end up reaching
out specifically to me and joe
and we're like what the [ __ ] they want
to audition this is crazy none of us
have really done any major auditions i
did little
little small things small projects here
and there like i was in a veterans
commercial and stuff like that but
nothing that was like that had this much
weight attached to the project title
and i remember um
we got the audition date but at the same
time we're coming back from a show
from doing a show like on the east coast
or something and then we got hit with
the email memorize
these three scripts you're gonna
audition with these three scripts and me
and you're like holy [ __ ] like we're on
the plane and we're gonna land and the
auditions tomorrow i'm like i guess
we're not [ __ ] sleeping on the plane
or when we get home we need to like
memorize these things as i'm reading i'm
like oh [ __ ] these are the [ __ ] this
is the written version of some of our
favorite sketches from the show so we're
practicing rehearsing and practicing
rehearsing [ __ ] hearts like
such a big thing
we go to the audition the next day we
walk into the room so
um when they hold these like
pre-production
like type operations they'll just rent
out a whole entire giant like two-story
[ __ ] 10-room office building just to
run pre-production castings here this is
here [ __ ] riders are over here so
it was on one of those like um
production lots
not in like a studio but you know how
the minute you exit like hollywood off
the 101 or even sunset off the 101
you'll see like just random big blob
productions good block productions yeah
yeah it's like one of those random
production videos one of those i was
like oh no this is what they're known
for they get rented out by random tv
shows or whatever
we pull in person of course asks for our
id and stuff and i'm like oh [ __ ] this
that [ __ ] movie [ __ ] oh [ __ ] they go
okay you're auditioning for this go up
to this room go upstairs
i remember going upstairs to the second
floor and then you see like in living
color on the door i'm like oh [ __ ] this
is where they're gonna do that [ __ ]
and i walk by the uh
the little like kitchenette where
there's like um fridge whatever and i
see marlon wayne's in there oh my oh
[ __ ]
that's the [ __ ] more than man the
[ __ ] group on this [ __ ]
watching wayne's bros you know
so we walk through and my heart's like
oh this is [ __ ] crazy we walk into
the actual like reception area and a lot
of the stand-up comedians white black
asian whatever of the time are all in
the same room so i guess they're like
trying to hire a tear like a yeah actual
comedian
um so i'm like oh [ __ ] so like
we're on youtube this is [ __ ] crazy
they see us at the same level i don't
even know and you see people kind of
just in their own zone like working on
[ __ ] right
uh there's probably like 15 of us
the
the casting person or the auditioning
person comes out and goes you know what
um scratch those scripts we don't want
that we want to do uh live improv
so just come in with whatever characters
and then uh we're gonna we're gonna do
that we'll see you guys in an hour and
then me and joe like oh like one it's
kind of like oh [ __ ]
on two levels one it's like cool this is
our strength but the second part is we
don't have any time to [ __ ] prepare
for this [ __ ] you have an hour what are
you talking about 60 minutes i don't
know that wasn't enough time for me so i
was like oh [ __ ] so my heart me and me
and joe like are you nervous it's tight
that you had joey yeah that was so cool
because we were both you both kept
checking and you guys have your
chemistry you know no but we're not
doing it together we're doing a separate
are you nervous oh yeah i'm so nervous
you're nervous too or both that's cuny
yeah we're both really nervous i
remember i was like i'll go pee
go down the hall i go p
as i'm peeing
keenan
v wayne
walks in
and then he's like peeing next to me and
then afterwards i was like
excuse me sir i just want to say uh i'm
the biggest fan i watched all of the
living color
and um i'm gonna audition see you later
and i pretty much probably had the most
awkward experience and he's just such a
nice like happy loving guy he just
smiles at me you know
and that was the first ocean moment of
like oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ] keenan ivory
wins this [ __ ] is like he's the
guy that started living color that
brought his whole family up like he's
the
the top dog you know
and then i go in the back i go back in
i'm like joe you're not before i just
cycle sword i saw [ __ ] keenan ivory
wayans and he's like what
i'm like yeah dude that's [ __ ] crazy
so now uh we we go our separate ways
because um i gotta work on my improv act
he has to work on our improv act even
though we're there together we're
auditioning separately
so you know when every comedian goes in
and goes in and goes in
finally it was
my turn
to go in
and uh when i go in it's not just keenan
it's keenan and like his two kids his
wife they're all sitting on the couch
and so pretty much they go
okay uh mr clown whenever you're ready
it was just him and no other people i
mean obviously his family but his
family's not producing the show yeah
just this kid's like it's like family
family so i think what they're trying to
do is like they want to make sure
whatever is happening hits on all levels
you know like the four quadrant in film
like whether it's like
senior citizens kids uh mid-twenties
married couples whatever so i think
to him he's like what better focus group
than my family
wow because if i don't laugh when my
kids are busting then that's like oh
[ __ ] that's it's hitting there or if i'm
laughing you know so i want to see how
this hits yeah so he has his whole
family there just sitting on the couch
and then the production coordinator who
was like mr kron uh whenever you're
ready you know and then so um what i
ended up doing was i did a my own
uh mixed act because you know i did all
kinds of characters
so like i had like a hispanic guy asian
guy some dude from the hood like some
redneck dude and i just did a one almost
like eddie murphy tyler perry theme that
was connected into a story so like i
would walk in and then there's like a
like a dude that was like get out of my
town and then i respond as this and then
another guy jumps in so i just did a
whole story that i just memorized
and the whole family was laughing and i
was like oh [ __ ] this is working this is
working you know you kind of have like
as your body is doing something you
could still kind of like be third person
i was like this [ __ ] racist crazy
this crazy i still can't believe i'm
making him laugh
and uh when i was done i was like
oh
and then i felt like i killed it but who
knows you know then joe's turn he comes
out he goes like doesn't you make him
laugh he goes yeah like oh [ __ ] i don't
know what's going to happen
and then
when the casting director hit us up
and uh was like both of you guys passed
the first audition
oh [ __ ] i remember this probably the
first time me and joe hugged because me
and joe are like not very emotional at
all and i think we both hugged just like
this is [ __ ] crazy only one or one
and they won both of us it's so [ __ ]
crazy
so i think
that's so cool yeah so i think we're
hugging for the first time ever and were
your dicks touching
i'm sure they were yeah both
uncircumcised dicks were touching i'm
sure and uh
they were hugging too
yeah then it was just crazy then all
these agents and stuff from hollywood
comes they came out of the woodworks i
don't even know how
but man if something is going to go
viral in the hollywood town it just it
just happens wme wants to have a meeting
ca wants to have a meeting like like
this person from this crazy agency once
like united artists once said like it
ever they're just like how the [ __ ] you
just keep eating voicemails
all right this is roger from caam and i
was almost i'm like how the [ __ ] these
[ __ ] get my number that's
[ __ ] great because we're so new to
this space we didn't even show up to the
audition with like headshot and resume
which is what what was the norm at the
time right
all the other stand-up comedians they're
so used to it they show a headshot and
resume for me and joel we just told the
casting director do you think i remember
her stuff so i don't even know where
they got our number or whatever and uh
but even like going through caa and
seeing those buildings that look all
crazy futuristic you know like [ __ ]
oprah is represented here tom cruise is
represented here that is oh [ __ ] yeah
you're just like oh sh and i could have
sworn um
sitting in front of me just in the couch
was moby
the dj yeah he's he's a pretty uh and at
that time he's huge not too many people
look like moby yeah and i was expecting
i was just sitting there and i was like
i think that's [ __ ] moby
and he's just [ __ ] sitting like a
regular person i was like
what the [ __ ] is going on damn yeah that
whole experience is [ __ ] crazy you
have a ton of oh [ __ ] moments like that
a lot of it did come from jk as you were
saying because i think that opened a lot
of doors and then we just kind of said
yes to you know
everything especially in that youtube
space uh at that time
it's a very like wild wild west so you
just did what felt right and you just
keep going yeah
damn
oh [ __ ] man i feel like we can keep
talking and going on for like [ __ ]
hours about this because like as you're
speaking i'm going oh yeah oh yeah i
have another one i have another one so
maybe we need like a part two yeah
that's what i was saying where i feel
like a lot of these things um
you know as we live life some of these
really cool memories kind of get buried
yeah and then um but they're so cool
that it happened that it's cool to share
with people because it's like it's a
peep into a different world or it's
extremely inspiring like and even like
my taika example
i'm sure he's gonna go through his
little oh [ __ ] moments i'm gonna be able
to relate to him on him or i could even
help him through some of them oh you
know what i would have done differently
if i were to audition for a big thing i
would have done it you know and i can
like it's just so cool that is super
cool
okay well then let us know in the
comments if we should be doing a part
two of all of our oh [ __ ] moments
because holy [ __ ] i got a ton
i'm sure you have a lot more too um so
yeah let us know thank you so much for
listening we'll catch you guys next week